[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you're anything like me
you believe that a glass of wine at
eight pm makes you a better mom
so port a supple glass let's talk it's
fall y'all in celebration of that I
found pumpkin spice wine I didn't know
that it was possible for me to be any
more basic but dreams do come true we're
gonna celebrate with a glass of that
it's not flavored it's literal pumpkin
wine which I thought only existed in
Harry Potter which is why I'm wearing
this sorting hat Cheers
Oh oh my god I gotta get something else
okay let's try this again I got some
real mom wine Chardonnay so with fall
comes my favorite holiday Halloween I
love it because I love candy and even
though I love Halloween not all good
things are perfect so let's talk about
the worst parts about Halloween first
the kids costume situation every year
starting in April
my son decides what he wants to be for
Halloween so I'll always get conned into
buying that costume and the next week he
changes his mind my rule is if he
doesn't change his mind for a month I
will buy the costume he's dead set on
being kylo Ren this year so we got the
costume I go to check out $50 $50 but
I'm like okay this is worth it it's in
all the Star Wars packaging and this
probably has like laser beams flying out
of it if it's $50 $50 we unwrap it and
it's literally one piece of fabric with
some slits on it and then a plastic mask
15 dollars to be worn one day of the
year and as a mom that's like offensive
I need everything to be worn to its
maximum capacity so if I'm spending $50
on a kylo Ren costume 15 dollars he's
gonna wear to school he's gonna wear it
to the park he's gonna wear it to
restaurants he's gonna wear it to
gymnastics class you keep that mask on I
don't care if you can't see tumble with
the mask on we're getting our money's
worth next the mom costume situation
because apparently if you're shopping at
a costume store as a mother you either
can have no body or show your entire
body
as a mother I feel like when I'm going
trick-or-treating with my kids there's
an expectation of me to have a modest
costume but I don't want to be a freakin
crayon for Halloween I wish there was
some type of middle ground costume that
I could buy cat woman meets cat lady a
cat woman but not skin tight like give
me a little room to breathe
maybe after she's retired and had a
couple of kids
that's the costume that I want if you're
looking to start a business
moderately sexy costumes for Mom you're
welcome
next the crash go throughout
trick-or-treating my child will ask for
a piece of candy from each house that we
visit and he'll be like oh my god but
mom they gave me a KitKat like you don't
know what a KitKat is know how to con me
better than that
come on he ends up eating pieces of
candy all along the way by the time we
get home both of my children are just
puddles of Marsh only 90s kids will
remember the Capri Sun commercials we're
like the kids turned into these
gelatinous like silver things and like
melted into the ground like that's what
my children turn into it then you have
to brush their teeth and they never want
to brush their teeth and it's like dude
you just ingested 80 cavities by the end
of the night it's like I've just fought
in the Crusades but it's all worth it
because once they fall asleep got
candies mine okay hats coming off feel
like I should look in the mirror last
Neil Patrick Harris we all know him we
all love him he is perfect his husband
is perfect their children are perfect
and instead of just like privately
enjoying it every year they post the
most perfect Halloween costume ensemble
that I have ever seen in my stupid
worthless life they always have the most
perfectly coordinated costumes tuned
it's always something popular but not
overdone that year how do they know that
they're going to be the only family just
as perfect Peter Pan character you have
Halloween all to yourself you are the
only people who are worthy of
celebrating this holiday when my family
tries to coordinate costumes we look
like a bunch of crazy people walking
down the street and then they always
take this perfect family photo in their
costumes everyone is looking at the
camera everyone's smiling I've
things perfect they all have their
makeup done they look beautiful when we
try to take a family photo someone's
always crying usually it's me someone's
always not looking at the camera
someone's probably pooping I just want
that Neil Patrick Harris vibe coming
from one of my pictures so like we get
it Neal
you're perfect we get it can you just
like post your Halloween picture in
November when the wound is a little less
raw so that we feel a little bit better
about ourselves and if you actually see
this Neil Patrick Harris Thanks big fan
of all your work let's like for today
I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom and if you guys know what
you're gonna dress up as for Halloween
leave it in the comments because I
desperately need ideas and if you have
couples costume ideas even better
because I want to convince my husband to
dress up with me because we're coming
for you Neil Patrick Harris you and your
perfect family we're coming for you and
we're going to take a beautiful picture
of all this coordinated with one random
kylo Ren in the corner it's gonna look
great till next time I'm always willing
to do that just like finish the glass
and just throw it down and walk away but
this is my house and I don't want to
have to clean it up
[Music]